you don't crash it who's it gonna fall
on obviously not the Mufflers in the
back it's gonna be like a face rain face
Apex face Alex or adapt or whatever like
and that's what's gonna fall on it's not
gonna fall on them it's gonna be on us
so we're gonna take the L for something
we didn't do again on July 20th 2022
FaZe Clan took their company public and
began trading on the stock exchange and
since that fateful day the stock has
plummeted from just under 10 US dollars
to 50 cents at the time of this
recording so
what the [__] happened
[Music]
last week perhaps faze's most popular
and also controversial member these
Banks took to Twitter to bash the
corporate side of their business this is
just the latest in what has actually
been a couple months now of many of the
company's public facing members
including most of its early members
taking shots at the company's corporate
management today I'm gonna try to break
down the big picture of what's been
going on with FaZe Clan recently there's
literally more than a dozen
dozen Yo's from members of FaZe Clan
there's tweets and posts all over the
Internet to sift through but I'm gonna
try to give you everything you need to
know so let's start with FaZe cleanse
IPO or initial public offering companies
do this when they want to take their
business public and allow people to buy
and sell shares of their company on a
stock exchange the purpose of taking
your company public is to make the
organization more prestigious and drive
the stock price up so you can grow your
business with that in mind after years
of being one of the most famous names in
all of gaming FaZe Clan went public on
July 20th 2022 evaluated at
725 million dollars it's a lot of money
the issue is that basically since that
day onward
the stock price has only gone down like
rapidly in fact recently faze's stock
Dove lower than one US dollar prompting
the stock exchange that are listed on
the NASDAQ to send them a notice of
delisting informing them that if they
didn't get their price back up over a
dollar they'd be taken off the exchange
less than a year since they went public
in this groundbreaking move for the
Esports World phases stock is tanking
the question is
why well if you've been paying attention
to the situation online lately or you're
a fan of FaZe Clan you'll know just as
well as I do that feels like everybody
has got an opinion on this thing over
the course of the last couple months
multiple OG members of FaZe Clan have
made videos and posted them to YouTube
and Twitter calling out the FaZe Clan
brass when I say that I mean the
corporate people the people they hired
to manage the business while they went
and created content and did YouTube
videos or phased up or whatever it is
they do so let's see if we can get to
the bottom of this I think the first
thing that's important to understand
here is that in order to take a company
public you probably have to hire some
non-esports and gaming staff you know
people in suits who have expertise and
things like accounting and finance and
things that aren't 360 no scopes that's
not to say that Banks and temper and
adapt and all those OG phase guys aren't
Savvy necessarily but you could see if
you're in their position they've made
their bag they just want to hand the
keys over to some business guys to steer
the ship well they go and make content
and party and buy sneakers or whatever
and that's what they've done gradually
over the course of the last five years
or so as some of you might remember from
the good old phase versus tfu Saga FaZe
Clan CEO wasn't any of those guys it
wasn't Banks or anyone you've seen on
YouTube it was a guy named Lee trink we
actually interviewed him three years ago
when all that was going down well look
obviously he's not representing us
anymore we can consider him still on
FaZe Clan until he's not on FaZe Clan
that's really it
um what does that mean I don't you know
I guess depends on depends on the on the
circumstance I can tell you how that how
that looks to the public but we consider
him a part of FaZe Clan until he's not a
part of FaZe Clan him just taking the
logos off of his Pages doesn't make him
out in many ways that Saga where tifu
was trying to get out of his talent
contract which he thought was
particularly restrictive to his earning
potential whereas where all of this
started because much like what's been
happening lately it's a phase Creator
clashing with the org's business son and
now Flash Forward a few years later
those same guys that turn the keys over
to someone like trink Apex temper Banks
rain they're taking to the internet to
call them out the same way tifu did and
many of them are saying that phases lost
touch of what the brand means what it
does what it stands for the sort of
authenticity that we all have associated
with FaZe Clan since the Call of Duty
days and before I get further into this
I don't want this to sound like I'm
being hypercritical of these faceless
guys in suits I don't know any of them I
don't even know if they've made mistakes
that's what's so difficult about this
story is that we don't actually get to
hear from any of these business types at
all ever since the IPO with that said
let me give you a few examples of what
these members of phase have been saying
that have been critical of the business
side of the operation and what's gone
down since the initial public offering
here's Tico saying enough is enough and
preparing to explain his side of things
and here's a part of a nine minute
YouTube video he published begging to be
taken seriously by phase fact that I
have to sit here and make a video
as someone who's been a member for 12
years to get anyone's attention to be
taken seriously is crazy to me and here
he is explaining that he was signed to
the exact same contract as tifu was this
entire time despite the fact that he
defended the org during that Saga the
only contract I've ever had with face
guess what contract that is the only
contract I ever had yes the tifu
contract the only contract I ever had
with face Reign also made what I think
is an astute point in his video about
how this financial downturn
isn't going to get blamed on the guys in
suits the corporate side of the business
it's gonna be blamed on the creators the
people that all the fans know and follow
on Twitter and follow on YouTube We're
stuffed what happens if the stock ends
up you know crashing who's it going to
fall on obviously not the mother's face
Apex phase or adapt or whatever like and
that's what's gonna fall on it's not
gonna fall on them it's gonna be on us
so we're gonna take the L for something
we didn't do again and here is rain
reacting to Tico and explaining that
while often rain and temper and banks
are referred to as the owners of FaZe
Clan the issues that Tico has are with
those same business people that I've
been talking about this entire time not
any of us and that's what you got to
realize when he talks about contract
it's not me banks Tommy and Apex or any
of us sitting in room all this like
owners is like how it used to be but
then when a business structure kind of
came in it's not us that's what just
everyone has to realize anybody who you
see with owner in their name like
they're not part of those meanings
they're not part of those decisions they
take what we say and impact their
decision maybe a little bit but
ultimately they're gonna do what they
want to do you so I just want you guys
all to know that so you don't think that
it's like us four in some suits sitting
in an office like we don't even talk
like that it's not like that at all and
this brings me to some of the specific
critiques of the current iteration of
FaZe Clan from its former members and
current members guys like Tico have been
critical of the commercialization of the
brand hammering away at collabs like
Batman and Champion well losing sight of
that traditional Esports and gaming
authenticity that we all know from FaZe
Clan like why don't we focus on
Counter-Strike instead of LeBron James's
son and Snoop Dogg and this trend
towards the commercialization is
something that both Tico and Reign
suggest that they don't agree with and
at the very least have not been properly
compensated for I did the champion
collab photo shoot and I have to go out
at seven in the morning to get pictures
for the shoot the same day
for free by the way while you sell the
draw for Millions no and that's true
that's what happens it's like they get
used to like promote the merchants it's
not like any of us get the money from
you oh where's the Batman you think I
made a dollar off being on the back
Batman cover you think I made a single
anything off anything I've been
advertised as a phase nothing and that's
what you got to realize they use us
they're just like puppets and they make
the money from and that's just the
realistic aspect to pay for more
incompetent employees we're gonna go do
more incompetent things and it's just oh
now despite the fact that many of faze's
public facing content creator side of
their business have been pretty aligned
throughout all of this there has been
some shade throne and adapt actually
addressed that in one of his recent
videos because we disagreed we had a
disagreement right he called me and he
was like yo
uh I want to make this video exposed to
FaZe Clan airing everything out I want
you to be in it
and I said no I said I don't want to do
that I feel like there's better ways we
could go to deal with these problems and
these issues more constructive ways of
showing up and dealing with these things
and
um we disagree just to make it clear
what we disagreed on it was the fact
that he was going to make a video about
it because I didn't think that was going
to help anyone I didn't think that was
the way in his video like rain and Tico
adapt says that despite the fact that
there has been some disagreements on the
Creator side he doesn't have much of a
say behind the scenes and is mostly just
trying to make small changes where he
feels like he actually can and it's for
this reason that I don't want to dive
too deep into all the drama on the
Creator side of the orc because while
there has been a lot said the situation
is obviously very complicated there's no
way for us on the outside to get all the
information and it has seemed like over
the course of the last couple months
these guys are banding together to try
to make changes to try to bring phase
back to what we all know and love the
org for so amidst the slew of videos and
with pressure from the entire Esports
gaming twitch and even business World
FaZe Clan dropped this
we know that for too long we haven't
been the phase we need to be but we are
working hard towards fixing that we hope
to have all the ogs sit down together
soon and we don't want to do that
without everyone we'll do everything in
our power to work this out and not let
you down a statement that Mr Beast had
some Choice words for certainly no
question where his Allegiance is lie and
that brings me to today phase is still
not worth a fraction of that original
public price it seems like a lot of this
drama has gone back behind closed doors
to sort this out and we're all left
wondering what the hell is going on this
was the first major Esports organization
to go public in this way in a way that
was supposed to be authentic and cool
and well
it flopped which does not bode well for
any others looking to do the same thing
and grow this Esports world that we all
love a sentiment which 100 thieves owner
nadeshot reinforced on his stream their
lack of success on the market is a
terrible thing for the Esports industry
as a whole man like people look at that
outside investors or people that want to
be a part of gaming and they want to
invest in it they won't touch it with a
100 foot pole back and forth back in
February I made a video right in this
room trying to unpack the sentiment that
Esports as a business was dying I dove
into the layoffs at 100 thieves all the
Esports team being bought by content
creators phases IPO and the absorbitant
costs associated with trying to run a
business at this scale when players
salaries and operational costs are this
hot and my resolution was mostly that
it's incredibly [__] hard especially
if you're not like literally Riot games
many of these orgs are trying to prop up
millions of dollars in operational costs
and salary costs with just advertising
dollars alone and it is simply not
working so guys like nadeshots are
trying to do anything they can create
products like energy drinks and
keyboards and hoodies and phase Clans
doing IPOs and collabing with Batman and
Superman and Ant-Man or whatever man
that they'll let them collab with to try
to figure this out no matter how smart
these guys are I don't think anyone has
all the answers right now but one thing
that is consistent about these
businesses is that they're trying to
combine the passion of OG's like Banks
and temper and nadeshot with the
business savvy of like traditional
corporate Executives in the case of
phase many of the members are calling
that very decision the problem yet in
the case of 100 thieves many in the
public were critical of nadeshot the
owner the founder of the OG himself
pursuing passion projects like juvie
over what was allegedly a lucrative
Partnerships business that they were
building internally the answer probably
lies somewhere between both of these
strategies merchandising energy drinks
Batman
traditional sponsorships get some
insurance companies to sponsor you Etc
so while in this case it really does
feel like something stinks at Phase I
can't bring it upon myself to feel like
getting the suits involved in the first
place was a bad idea in many ways what
these guys are going through the phases
the Optics the hundred thieves even the
tsms it's Paving a path it might be a
path of what not to do
but it is a path and so since I don't
have all the answers I ask you guys what
you think should Esports stay relatively
small should we leave the managing and
the vision to the true ogs or should we
be reaching out to these traditional
business types to try to bring us to
infinity and beyond to the promised land
let me know in the comments
[Music]
thank you